ending the season in the middle of a
boss fight is bound to leave viewers
with lots of questions but the outcome
of that tussle isn't the end of the
mysteries in warrior not here's a look
at the biggest unanswered questions we
have about the Netflix hits first season
you must have a million questions the
first friend Ava makes after her
awakening is JC a charming thief
squatting in a wealthy vacation home
with his compatriots Ava is attracted to
JC right away
a romance develops and JC eventually
splits from his fellow thieves to help
Ava even though there's clearly so much
that Ava hasn't told him at the end of
episode 5 JC is there when a monstrous
Tarasque materializes and seemingly
slays sister Lilith he's understandably
freaked out and in the following episode
Mary tells Ava that he promptly ran away
from the scene so is that it for JC
will we see him again well neither he
nor Ava exchange the l word they seem to
care quite a bit for each other of
course watching a demon impale a nun is
probably enough to spoil just about any
romance not to mention that at this
point either JC nor Ava have any clue
where the other is it may be that the
craziness of Ava's life is too much for
JC but who knows the unfinished battle
of the season finale seems pretty public
it takes place in Vatican City the David
a new pope is named it could be that JC
might see Ava fighting demons on TV
decide to throw caution to the wind and
come back do you hear a lot of echoes of
shows like Buffy the Vampire Slayer and
supernatural and warrior not one pretty
big trope from those earlier series we
see repeated is the hero seemingly
killed and pulled into hell only to
return with new purpose and power well
sister Lilith seems to have sacrificed
herself at the end of episode 5 she
shows up covered in cuts and dried blood
at the end of episode 7 she displays
abilities similar to those of the
Tarasque s-- and the scar where she was
impaled radiates with what appears to be
demonic energy while she doesn't seem to
remember what happened to her she knows
things the other heroes don't most
importantly she knows it's a mistake to
allow Ava to enter aid riyals tomb so
what happened to sister Lilith what's
keeping her alive and what's our who
sends her back if we assume as her
fellow sisters believe that sister
Lilith was dragged into hell than the
obvious answer is at its a forces of
Hell who sent her back fully equipped
with new abilities and knowledge but
while that may be the easiest answer it
leads to more questions she seems to be
work
with the OCS and the warrior nun and why
would the armies of satan make an ally
with a secret catholic warrior sect
you've been to the other side
battalion doesn't matter but I know what
you really are one of the welcome
aspects of warrior nun is that its
characters often turn out to be more
than they first appear and Mother
Superior on is a perfect example past
were training the sister warriors in the
warrior nun Mother Superior on initially
expresses nothing but disdain for Ava
she's hard nosed unforgiving and even
cruel throughout the first season we
hear a number of characters referring to
Superion spaz without getting into
details and eventually we learned she
was briefly one of the halo bearers
before the artifact rejected her
rejected me dual candidates are with it
but there's still plenty we don't know
about Mother Superior and the most
obvious question involves her prominent
facial scar could the scar have
something to do with the halos rejection
in particular it's difficult to hear
Mother Superior on story and not think
of the journal entry sister Beatrice
reads about the world war ii era warrior
nun who escaped from the concentration
camps could it be that like the earlier
warrior non mother Superion lashed out
with the Halos power and hatred and
that's why the artifact rejected her you
might think that since warrior nun is
based on a comic book we could figure
out the answers to all these questions
by checking out the source material but
warrior nun is fairly different from the
comics in a number of ways including the
identity of its protagonist Ava was
created specifically for the Netflix
series and most of the comics the hero
is sister Shannon which happens to be
the name of the warrior nun who dies in
episode 1 sister Shannon returns in
episode AIDS as part of Ava's dream
shannon surprises Ava by speaking with
nothing but regret for what she and the
previous warrior nuns fought and died
for believing it's all been futile Ava
seems to believe that it isn't merely a
dream but an actual communication with
the departed sister Shannon it's this
dream that inspires Ava to tell her
allies their mission has changed and
that she plans to destroy the bones of
Adriel but considering what happens in
the following two episodes we have to
ask if it was truly the spirit of sister
Shannon to whom a bespoke going to aid
riyals tomb with the intent of
destroying his bones is what ends up
being Adriel suggesting it could
possibly be Adriel who psychically
communicated with ava and disguise
himself as Shannon at the same time
Adriel tries to take the halo from Ava
big things are happening at jillion
salvus laughs Gillian's alien son
Michael insists that his mother bring
him to the Ark telling her the door is
about to open as he predicts the art
spontaneously comes to life and Michael
runs through the quantum portal
beckoning his mother and follow Joey and
runs to the portal but it closes before
she reaches it
[Music]
where could michael be well the answer
to that is obviously tied to the
question of where the quantum portal
leads Julian seems to think heaven is on
the other side of the portal or
something very much like what we think
of as heaven cardinal do reti expresses
the fear that it actually leads to hell
we have no way of knowing if either all
right or even close one thing that does
not bode well for Michael is that he
constantly refers to the angel who has
been communicating with him if it's
Adriel who's been in contact with
Michael then that's not good now that we
know that Adriel is no angel there's no
reason to think you wouldn't happily put
Michael at risk for his own ends in the
beginning we're told Adriel is an angel
in the season finale
Ava calls him a devil but by the end of
season one we don't really have a clear
idea of who or what Adriel is what do we
know what we know when he appears on
earth during the Crusades Adriel is
being pursued by the Tarasque s-- he
forges an alliance with Ariella the
first warrior nun and builds armor from
the divinium in the tourists corpses we
know that he has an unnaturally long
life can heal from just about any wound
and appears to have some sort of control
over the rape demons one possibility
comes straight from Adrian's mouth when
Ava asks if he's an angel
he says that's a closest approximation
she could understand this could suggest
that neither Adriel nor any of the
so-called demons are creatures of hell
but rather something else entities of
unknown origin who have been
misinterpreted through the lens of
religion we are the same you and I we've
both been some stood if on the other
hand were meant to see the supernatural
beings from the show as creatures from
either heaven or hell and that makes
things more complicated because we're
left with a question of why one demonic
being Adriel is in conflict with other
demons nothing in warrior Nuns first
season makes you want to go back and
re-watch it more than when Father
Vincent walks up to Adriel and calls him
master at that moment we know it's
Vincent not to ready who has been the
traitor inside the OCS and most
tragically the one who has sister
Shannon killed in the first episode it
makes it tempting to go right back to
the beginning and re-watch the series
paying special attention to father
Vincent's actions
who we have to wonder exactly when
Adriel recruited his servant within the
OCS it puts a whole new spin on the
revelations at Vincent has a less than
wholly even criminal past could it be
that Adriel reached out and recruited
Vincent even before he was ordained as a
priest could Vincent have joined the
priesthood with the goal of implementing
the OCS and freeing his master and what
exactly could it be expecting in return
for his treachery
Vincent's played a long game and
committed dark acts to achieve his
master's goal what could a jury will be
promising him he doesn't seem like
someone interested in wealth or power
but obviously he's fooled us before is
it possible he actually thinks he's
doing the right thing according to the
backstory of the OCS the order has
operated completely in the shadows over
the centuries the events of warrior
announced per season raised the question
of whether it will be possible for the
OCS to keep itself a secret anymore
and if they can't stay a secret will
they be allowed to exist at all the
first time we see the OCS get more of
the spotlight than there used to is when
Julie and salvus releases video to the
press of sister Beatrice making short
work of her lab security force
however Beatrice isn't identified and
Jillian doesn't mention the OCS by name
though she does say the perpetrator is
an operative of the Catholic Church we
have to assume the battle in the season
finale will likewise get plenty of
attention and it may be tougher for the
sister warriors involved to hide their
identities the battle is in the Vatican
City right after a new pope is named and
there's no way there won't be dozens of
smartphones recording the melee as it
happens how can the OCS operate after
that how would things go in the real
world the video was released of nuns
shooting a prone man in the back of the
neck with a crossbow doesn't seem like
those nuns would stay out of prison for
very long things really don't look good
for shotgun Mary at the end of season
one facing down the crowd of possessed
civilians her friends repeat the OCS
mantra in this life on the next both
shot guns drawn Mary fights off a few
the possessed but the mob soon
overpowers her the season finale ends
with Mary disappearing in a crowd of the
possessed crying out in pain we're
guessing and hoping that Mary will
survive to return in season two things
may not look good for her right now but
as the events of the first season make
abundantly clear she's one of the
toughest members of the OCS that Ridge
still you can never be sure as tough as
she is Mary gets easily knocked off her
feet by just a single possessed villager
in Episode six now she's being swallowed
by an entire mob of the things some of
whom are possessing the elite Vatican
Swiss Guards who are formidable even
without demonic passengers and let's not
forget even if Mary and her friends find
a way to escape the possessed without
killing them they still have Adriel to
deal with check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite Netflix
originals are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]